[Music]
i'm edward carr the economist deputy
editor hello my name is callum williams
i'm senior economics writer at the
economist and i
am joining ed to answer your questions
on this call
about a month ago we did a q a on
covid19
and all its implications well a lot's
happened since then
we thought we'd come back and answer
some more questions so here we are
[Music]
there have been reports of people um
who have apparently tested uh
that they've been cured from disease who
then do seem to get a new infection
but really that's very hard to interpret
um there could be reasons for that
one is that fat community might not last
another is that the test that they had
wasn't accurate a third could be that
they hadn't actually properly got rid of
the disease and it's flared up again
this question of bad immunity is really
important obviously because
um it affects what happens when people
who think they've had the disease
then go out and if they can catch it
again or spread it it might be
might be an important have an important
effect on their behavior
but the really the thing about diseases
is that the immune system shows a very
very wide range of responses
in some diseases like measles you get
immunity for a lifetime
in others like the cold for instance or
flu
you might get immunity for six months a
year
uh and it's really too soon to say where
on that spectrum
covid19 lies we've only had it for four
months
so it's just too soon impossible to know
whether this immunity lasts
[Music]
a lot of people have said well if the
economy does badly then
public health will do badly and there's
a lot there's a lot to that argument um
the way to think about it though is the
is to look at the historical evidence
for this
and what that shows is when there have
been past pandemics the uh
the countries that tended to lock down
or cities that tended to lock down
fastest and earliest
over the medium and long run tended to
have much better economic outcomes in
things like
wages and employment and business growth
and so on so
even if you just look at it from an
economic perspective there's a very
strong argument
in favor of of of lockdowns so the
lockdowns do in themselves have
costs they have costs in mental health
uh there's costs in domestic violence
some people don't get treated for
diseases they might
just might either get treated for so
there are costs it's just that those
costs
in the long run are so much smaller than
the costs of letting the disease
run wild
well this is an important question
because um you can imagine that
the moment a vaccine is demonstrated to
be safe the demand for it will be
huge you know everybody on the planet
will want this vaccine
and there are a number of worries about
that uh
you know there is a there's a
distribution that is optimal
in in terms of the common good and that
is for
health workers for instance to get to
get the
vaccine very early because they need to
be protected when they come to care and
look after people
then you'd probably pick the vulnerable
which for this disease
is the elderly and people who have you
know pre-existing conditions
and you'd work your way through the
population according to
vulnerability and risk but there's a
you know there's a chance that the
country that happens to
either invented the vaccine or to have
the
facilities that can manufacture it that
or has indeed has the money to buy it
that those countries will start to
corner the market
so there are moves now particularly
among the g20 encouraged by the who
to try and set up systems today before a
vaccine has been
discovered and approved to have you like
to appeal to the better side of
everybody's nature and agree
with through the veil of ignorance as to
what's the best way of of doing this
um but that i think will be challenged
um
and and sort of you know self-interest
understandably but self-interest will
at least challenge that system
[Music]
swedish cases is the kind of million
dollar question that no one really knows
the answer to
when you when you talk when you read or
listen to interviews with the various
epidemiologists
um who are who are in charge of that uh
program they will say that it's
it remains too early to tell uh you know
how successful otherwise their strategy
has been
um there has already has already come
with a very clear economic cost
uh as particularly as people in older
age brackets have have
held back and haven't gone out and that
kind of thing um in terms of the number
of deaths i mean they're not doing
as badly as you might have thought
certainly when you compare deaths per
person with other countries the
epidemiology i've seen suggests that
sweden's cases are
are going up um reasonably fast um but
but you just have to
to see uh at with time what happens
because
supposing their second and third waves
the sort of lockdowns
that you've seen for instance the united
states i think will be very hard
to introduce repeatedly you know i think
in some ways if sweden keeps the cases
down
it's much more sustainable to have a
policy that's more voluntary
people will do it and i think that was
part of the
thinking behind the british approach
originally but you know in britain it
didn't work britain had a lot of cases
it wasn't happening
the swedes claim to be naturally
naturally socially distant
because of the temperament of the swedes
that's what they say about themselves so
you know maybe it's easier there
but these things are these things are
experiments and some people get it right
and some people get it wrong
the epidemiology so far and it's not
complete but so far
suggests one that children aren't in
particular danger they don't catch the
disease
any more readily than adults possibly
less actually
and if they do catch the disease they
don't die from it um so so that means
that you aren't actually putting
children themselves in danger by going
to school but you aren't really putting
their families in danger particularly
either
these are very sparse studies so far but
uh in iceland and the netherlands um
they suggest that the children
haven't passed on the disease to their
families from school now that
that might be just because schools
actually happen to close very early so
you haven't had
much opportunity to and you know as
countries like denmark and germany now
begin to open schools you might see
evidence of transmission
within them which would have to
obviously change policy it's a very
interesting example of how to think
about this
as you should i i think in in all of
these social existencing measures which
is
they come at a cost and they come with a
benefit it turns out the benefits of
this perhaps aren't as large as people
thought but the costs are really very
high indeed particularly to the children
themselves who might miss out on many
months of education setting them back by
some research shows up to a year um
and and also to their parents who
obviously can't
work because they have to be at
home-minded kids
[Music]
in economic terms it looks uh it looks
pretty worrying
um what we see at the moment in the
financial markets is that
rich countries in particular countries
like the uk the us germany
australia japan there's enormous demand
for safe assets
and that safe assets in that context
really means the government debt of
those countries so they're finding it
actually
sort of surprisingly easy to borrow vast
sums in order to
subsidize wages and give grants to
businesses and
all that kind of stuff now this is a
luxury that most um
emerging markets or poor countries uh
have to a much either to a much lesser
extent or or not at all
and so in terms of being able to support
their economy um
it's they have much less room for
maneuver
and bear in mind also that they have a
much higher incidence of things like
informal work
so people who are not sort of officially
employed and therefore
are not able to access you know some of
the welfare state privileges that people
in
the rich world would have some poor
countries
some bits of poor countries kerala and
india for instance
and vietnam um have done extremely well
in stopping the spread of the disease so
you know social distancing is not high
tech
it's harder in crowded cities and it's
harder to be to have wash your hands
when you have to cue
one water stand for many buildings but
it is possible to have social distancing
for me the real question i think is sort
of
what happens next um you know
people do not have savings to fall back
on
they need to to work um and
uh it may be that a vaccine
or a cure is many many it's likely that
it's many many many months away
so um you know the the the
transmission of the disease in india has
slowed is now about doubling about once
every 10 days
and they've extended the lock down and
the lockdown remains
popular there but it can't last for
months and months and months
the first thing is to get a real
understanding of how
um covid19 or other um
cov2 the virus that causes it how that
went from bats to people
we need to understand that because
coronaviruses
it's a fat one of this family of seven
viruses of the pyrion people but three
um kovid 19 sars and mers
have appeared in people in the last 20
years having not really
caused people many problems at all
before then so
something has happened to mean that
these viruses have come back again and
again
that's the first thing i think is sort
of better understanding of the virology
and that involves china being willing to
open up and let people find out what's
going on and it's putting up a big
resistance to that at the moment then
clearly
the second thing we've seen is that the
who
was either unable to put its message
across or didn't feel it had the power
to
be exactly as explicit as it was it
wanted
about what was happening in china first
of all and then warning people but the
who is a creature of the governments
that created it including the united
states
and it doesn't have enormous political
power so a second question is to ask
are governments prepared to give the
who or something like it a bit more
oomph
and a bit more teeth the third thing is
preparedness um it it's really
interesting how the countries that have
done best with covert 19
are those that had already been through
something like it with sars
i'm thinking of taiwan singapore hong
kong
and those countries learned important
lessons with sars that they then were
able to apply
uh with kofit 19. i think that'll happen
on its own but each country needs to go
through its response
to think about what worked and what
didn't so that they're properly prepared
and one of the questions that they'll
need to answer i think
is to what extent do they need to feel
that they produce their own supplies
of medical equipment and drugs
i think it'll be a big debate to be had
on that we like to think we bring you
the best coverage
of curvid19 and all its implications for
the economy
for politics and for science
one of the ways we do that is we produce
a weekly covid 19 newsletter
and if you'd like to subscribe to that
please click on the link opposite
thank you for watching